[Music]
we give like a surprise event frog I
got7 yeah the fans are taking a quiz to
see which custom remember they are yeah
no idea that we're here are we gonna
Surprise them are you ready I'm always
ready oh oh let's go why I love thought
7 is because it was the first group that
actually called me into kpop or
something about their music and like
they're vibing that they're so diverse
it's like really amazing because they
can connect to so many people all three
of us into their concert we waited yeah
yeah we're waiting there's also like
official colors okay cool glow sticks
it's also a fan chants then when you're
at the concert you're not just watching
them you're interacting with them really
I woke up I don't know they're just
amazing like how can you not like
[Applause]
you guys have any question 7 let's hear
a favorite part about performance maybe
when you guys all Devin actually is you
know the best product conservative you
guys did the best yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we know that we're not really ever going
to meet them because some of us will
ever really have a chance to go to Korea
to actually be able to get this
opportunity makes me like so emotional
and then you want to be something more I
was more nervous than I got seventeen to
be very honest woke up Gator kids never
gonna feel okay yeah I think is the
honor and is really good memories to me
I couldn't believe that we got seven
again can I talk excuse me express your
feeling with one dance move three two
one